all right it's time to get you ready for
the divisional round weekend shireen
williams mike florio with you on pftpm
we've got
several different categories of of uh
ways to look at this and we're going to
pick some players in response to each
one let's begin with who has the most
pressure of the players in these four
games coming up over saturday and sunday
shireen
well happy birthday drew brees turned 42
today mike and you alluded to this
earlier right
tom brady's older but we don't get the
feeling that tom brady is ready to
retire yet we do get the feeling that
this might be drew brees's last year
whether he wants to retire or whether
the saints are ready to move on whatever
the case may be
injuries over the last couple years this
just to me
seems like the end for drew brees and
this is his last post season to add a
super bowl ring of course he only has
the one
that came in 2009 and this has been not
been a good team in the postseason
over the last four years 49 and 15 in
the regular season they've gone three
and three in the postseason
they lost to the vikings at home in
overtime last year they lost the rams at
home and overtime in 2018 of course i
think we all agree they should have won
that game
uh based on an official decision late
there in regulation but it didn't happen
and now here they are perhaps in drew
brees's last
chance and a chance to end it like
peyton manning
ended it and it does feel a lot like
peyton manning's last year mike
yeah you know it really does and uh
we'll see whether or not brees can
advance to the next round
it's hard for him it's got to be
excruciating excruciatingly difficult
for him to walk away from the game after
losing at home to tom brady and he's
done very well against tom brady so
i agree with you a ton of pressure on
drew brees this weekend i think there's
a ton of pressure on jared goff
jared goff who some would say has kind
of fallen out of favor
with sean mcvay the coach of the rams
maybe mcveigh would have preferred to go
with john wolford at quarterback this
weekend maybe mcveigh sees wolford as a
guy who can
better run the offense then goff goff
making 33.5 million dollars a year under
his current contract
and playing out in the cold remember
2018 when the rams had that sunday night
game in chicago
jared goff was affected by the cold and
there were no
elements it was just cold there was no
wind or rain or snow
or sleet it was just cold and it's going
to be cold in green bay
and there won't be much wind and
there'll be no snow or sleet or freezing
rain or anything like
that but we need to see him step up
and help that rams offense outscore
whatever the rams defense
can hold the packers offense to it's
going to be on goff
to engineer at least one more point
and if he fails badly in that spot
you're gonna hear
all off season long why did the rams
give him that much money
i still think they shouldn't have and i
said it from the get-go and when can we
get rid of him and sorry rams fans but
you're stuck with him for at least a
couple more years
yeah mike since he became the starter in
week 11 of his rookie season he's been
like the quarterback he's been their
franchise guy and it doesn't have that
same
feel now to me it seems like there is a
question there and a question within
sean mcveigh's mind of whether he is the
guy
yeah and uh we'll see if he can
get himself back in mcvay's good graces
on saturday
first game out of the gates in division
around weekend all right what's the
biggest surprise you're anticipating
this weekend shireen
well mike i think the browns are going
to make it a competitive game with the
chiefs now i'm not ready to say the
browns are going to win this game but i
do
think it's going to be a competitive
game when you look at patrick mahomes
he hasn't played mike since december
27th and we haven't talked about this
and the last time he played it was a
blah game they beat the falcons 17-14
december 13 was the last time
he threw for over 300 yards so he has
not played well
in a really long time now is he just
gonna flip that switch and turn it back
on he certainly did that last year we'll
see if he can do it this year
but everybody seems to have forgotten
mike that it took
three comebacks in the postseason last
season to win
the super bowl can they do that again
can they avoid
having to come back in each of the games
which is really hard to do
and patrick mahomes like any great
player looking for motivation wherever
he can find it odell beckham jr had a
tweet recently suggesting
that he believes the browns will win the
game patrick mahomes clicked the like
button
on it a source of potential drive
added on top of the effort to become the
first team to repeat as champions
since the 2003-2004 patriots and i think
they can keep it close shereen and i'm
of the mindset and
coach dungey and i disagreed about this
earlier this week and he's coach dungy
so he automatically wins
he thinks the browns need to get up into
a shootout
i think the browns need to slow it down
run the ball take the full play clock
tell baker mayfield your your game
manager not gunslinger
and reduce the number of possessions
that the chiefs have
yeah i'm with you mike i think they
definitely have to run the ball well if
they're going to have a chance in this
game and keep the ball out of patrick
mahomes possession
what i think's gonna happen that will be
a surprise at least in hindsight i think
the buffalo bills are going to unleash
josh allen as a runner we saw it in the
wild card round last year he had 92
rushing yards and he caught a touchdown
pass
an 18-yarder he had over 100 yards from
scrimmage
other than as a quarterback this past
week and people were like oh he really
ran a lot he only had 54 yards he just
doesn't run as much now because
he can get it done with his arm i think
in a game where we're going to see
plenty of
lamar jackson running for the ravens
this is going to be the thing that can
maybe bust open the ravens defense if
alan can run like jackson runs and i
know the ravens defense will be better
prepared for it because they see jackson
in practice but just because you see him
doesn't mean you can stop him
and i think we should expect to see josh
allen run the ball more than he did last
week
and i think he's going to have the green
light anytime he sees an opening if
they're blanketing stefan diggs
if they're covering cole beasley if
they're taking away john brown and
gabriel davis
josh allen tuck it and take off and i
think it will stun the ravens
defense to see josh allen run it the way
that he's capable of running it shireen
and they're also missing zach moss mike
so i i think this could be another
element to their
running game is josh allen and he did
have 11 carries
last week the last four regular season
games he had
15 total carries he had 11 last week so
i'm with you
i think they've decided that hey it's
the postseason throw caution to the wind
let josh allen run because he's very
good at it
let's go to another topic this
officially is called the under the radar
storyline
in uh deference to chris sims i'll call
it the swept under the radar storyline
that's one of the sims isms he gave us
this week
what is your swept under the radar
storyline
well i like the fact that kevin
stefanski's coming back to call the
plays i mean alex van pelt was terrific
last week he didn't take uh the the foot
off the gas
mike you kept thinking pittsburgh's
getting back in this
they're scoring you're gonna see the the
browns
try to run this out nope they said we're
gonna throw the ball we're going to
match you touchdown for touchdown and
you can't come back against us
and alex van pelt did not have kevin
stefanski there to to change his mind or
anything else it was his game
and he called a terrific game and now
kevin stefanski's coming back his first
playoff game
is the head coach of the browns his
first playoff game as a play caller
what's he going to do
and how much is he going to rely on alex
van pelt this week
they had total balance last week 31
rushes in 34 passes
it helps to get out to that easy seven
nothing lead and to have it snowballed
into 28 nothing but
you're right it's actually extra
pressure on kevin stefanski because
if they stink on on sunday afternoon
maybe people will say next time we're in
the playoffs we just need to lock you in
the basement and go with someone else
running the team that day
for me the under the radar storyline is
antonio brown back in the superdome for
the first time in two years the last
time we saw him there was his last game
with the steelers just a few days before
he got upset that juju smith schuster
was named the team mvp
and he threw the ball at ben
roethlisberger and stormed off and never
came back he had 14 catches for 185
yards and two touchdowns
against the saints in the superdome he's
in game shape
game speed ready to go they've got a
vast array of weapons
but when when mike evans got hurt in
week 17 antonio brown really stepped up
and had a huge day
then they didn't need him much last
saturday against washington
i think they're going to need him on
sunday and i think we're going to see a
lot of antonio brown
because he's back in a building shireen
where he's made
plenty of noise at least the last time
he played there
absolutely mike and he hasn't had the
greatest of postseason careers 11
postseason games five 100 yard games and
five touchdowns but i do think with
marshawn lattimore on mike evans we
could see a lot of a b
this week all right next one
best head-to-head match-up this weekend
shireen what do you got
well i'm gonna go with the obvious one
mike and it's the packers number one
scoring offense against the rams
number one scoring defense it's happened
six
times before that the number one scoring
offense has met the number one scoring
defense
and the offenses to no one's surprise
are four and two but
then that's in the divisional round
overall since 1990 the defenses
actually have a four to three lead in
that but i am intrigued by this the
packers had the number one scoring
offense in 2014 and the seahawks beat
them
uh 28-22 they were the number one
scoring defense that year so this this
matchup just intrigues me about who's
going to win it
rams definitely need to do what they've
been doing which is score defensive
touchdowns if they're going to have a
chance
and i look at two specific aspects of
that matchup
packers offense against rams defense
number one jaylen ramsey on devonta
adams will aaron rodgers throw it even
if devonte
adams isn't technically open will there
be a crevice a sliver a crease through
which he can get the ball
to adams and will he catch it even if
he's covered second
aaron jones contract year post season
he had three 100 yard rushing games this
year back in week two against the lions
he had over 200 yards from scrimmage it
looked like he was going to make a huge
statement
to get paid a ton of money by somebody
it didn't happen the way that we thought
it would
it can happen now with 24 teams watching
this is his chance to get people to
start scratching his name
near the top of the list of available
running backs in free agency so
i agree where you're coming from here
that offense versus that defense
what are they going to do to slow down
aaron rodgers and company and what can
that supporting cast do to step up to
help save the day
for me the best head-to-head matchup is
the chief's pass rush
against baker mayfield because as long
as baker mayfield isn't being rushed
isn't being hurried isn't being
pressured he can execute the offense now
that's true for most quarterbacks
but it's especially true for baker
mayfield because
he's he's somewhere between tom brady
and patrick mahomes and i he's not
closer to either one maybe he's closer
to my homes
but he's not all that he's not as mobile
as the
aaron rodgers josh allen's patrick
mahomes of the world
he can buy sometime with his feet but
not enough
and if you get it's almost like kirk
cousins plus a little extra mobility
where you can you can get outside the
pocket but if someone is chasing you
down
it's going to disrupt you it didn't
happen against the steelers
they didn't have tj watt in his face i
thought that would happen to me can the
chiefs get through
the browns offensive line and get after
baker mayfield shireen
and if they can't that's great news for
the browns
and that was one of the key story
storylines from last week mike baker
mayfield took
no sacks after taking four in each of
the previous two games that's huge for
the browns they need to protect him joel
bitonio coming back is really going to
help
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports